Chicago freakanomics a rogue economist
explores the hidden side of everything
is number 2 on this week's New York
Times nonfiction bestseller list it's
published by William Morrow an imprint
I'm Barbra Meade I'm one of the owners
here at politics and prose and I have a
real pleasure tonight to introduce
Steven Levitt who was the co-author of
this new book Freakonomics a rogue
economist explores the hidden side of
everything I was read the book I enjoyed
it a great deal but even at the end I
was mystified about what a rogue
economist was so I just I just been
sitting back in the office asking Steven
Levitt what is the road rogue economist
I mean I want to make sure that it was
not somebody who was dangerous but it
but it turns out that a rogue economist
is somebody that is not the first
definition of rogue which is a scoundrel
it is somebody who is the second
definition of rogue which is fun-loving
mischievous and that certainly is a good
description of this book the book the
book is a pure delight and for
Washington audiences I thought it has
some very special appeal and two of the
areas where that he kind of turns
conventional wisdom on its head
for it for things that concern us one
the conventional wisdom says that there
must be some correlation between the
crime rate and the size of a police
force in other words if you don't have
that many police around you're good to
have a high crime rate if you have a lot
of police around you're gonna have a low
crime rate well as it turns out
Washington DC has three times the size
the police force of Denver Colorado we
have eight times the number of murders
of Denver of Denver Colorado and Steven
Levitt
sure we'll explain of how this
conventional wisdom gets turned on its
head there and then of course it what's
always important to us here in
Washington is campaign finance the
conventional wisdom is the candidate who
collects the most money will be the
winner it's true but it's not that money
produces winning candidates it's at
winning candidates produce money and he
will explain that also I want you all to
be sure to know that he that steven
levitt has been awarded the James Bates
Bates Clark award which is for the medal
which is given every two years to the
best economist under 40 so it's our
special privilege to have in this room
tonight and we'll be able to see when he
talks of why that he has gotten this
award
so here's Steven Levitt
thank you all for coming one thing I can
say for sure as an economist is that
whoever set the prices for seats set the
price way too low tonight we'd all be
better off if there have been a cover
charge up front but anyway thank you all
for coming I have a confession to make
which is that I have never done a book
reading before in fact I have only been
to one in my entire life and it was
David Sedaris and so I don't think it
was very good model for what I'm
planning on doing today so I'm just
gonna wing it and I try not to talk for
too long and then leave plenty of time
for for people to ask questions so in
particular actually I wasn't gonna talk
about either of the issues you were
gonna bring up neither crime or
campaigns money although I'm happy to
take questions on those I was going to
tell just a story of a few stories and
its really the story of Sudhir Venkatesh
and how I met Sudhir Venkatesh and and
the research that that came out of that
that meeting because I think it captures
in many ways the flavor of this book
better than any other story in the book
at least it's my favorite story that's
in the book and it's this book is about
many different things it's about you
know the part I'm going to talk about
now which is why drug dealers live with
their mothers if they're if they're you
know living so large and it's about
campaign spending it's about why crime
went down in the 1990s it's about
whether the first name that you give to
your child has any impact on their life
outcomes and it's about parenting so
it's hard to convey in a short period of
time the feeling of the book but the
book is really ultimately it's about
data and about my attempts I supposed to
be a data detective and to search for
truth in data but to tell stories that
make it more interesting than the usual
searches for truth in data so let me let
me go back to when I first met Sood even
before I met four dear so I was lucky
enough to be at the Society of fellows
at Harvard which is this amazing elite
academic institution that I that I
lucked into by virtue of
having the best the wittiest
conversational net of my life when i
needed to have it and that gave me three
years to do whatever I wanted with no
obligations and so and with these great
scholars dr. Marcus and Nobel Prize
winning physicist and so I heard that in
the next group that was coming with a
guy named Sudhir Venkatesh and everybody
raved about Syria Venkatesh he was a he
was an ethnographer someone who who did
went out in the field and and and lived
with people and study their behavior and
wrote about it so I figured well I'll
look up this guy and see what he's all
about so the only thing he had published
at that time I found was an article in a
post modern sociology journal and the
title was rappin wit a gangsta okay that
was the name of the article that wasn't
exactly my thing and I would my tastes
were a little more narrow back then but
I said I'll go get it out of library
anyway so I got it and I was surprised
because it was really just a
conversation
it was Sudhir talking with a gang leader
and and again I was thinking is this you
know how is this scholarship what it
says but the thing was the more I read
it the more I read this is really it was
interesting and I learned a lot and yeah
I remember a few things from it that was
vintage so this was a college-educated
gang leader who had worked in the
management information systems the
computer have had a data part of a
downtown business in Chicago before he
said wait a second this is a waste of my
time I can make more money running the
gang I'm gonna drop out of that and go
to the gang so what was interesting I
said here was this this gang leader who
had lived on both sides really of the of
you know culture the law and the thing I
remember that was maybe most interesting
was that he said you know the police are
very unfair and you know it turns out in
fact the police are I think very unfair
or not even but what he said that was
interesting was he said you know the
gangs are out killing people I don't
deny that that we're all killing people
and we get some heat for that but what
really bothers me is that the guys who
are running anheuser-busch and and
Miller
we know they're killing the you know
they're killing each other too but why
doesn't it media cover that and Ford and
General Motors we know that they're
killing all the executives from the
other companies but why doesn't the
media cover it and it was just very
striking because amidst all of this
discussion which made total sense and
showed a real understanding of the world
by this gang leader there was this other
piece which is least as far as I know is
completely counterfactual and it was and
it really opened my eyes to thinking
about what you could learn from this
approach so then I met sit here and at
the time I was I was doing some really
uninteresting work trying to model in
theory what gangs were doing until I met
Sudhir we began talking and immediately
liked him and so in that first
conversation I said well it's too bad
you don't have any data you know if you
just had some data this would be he's so
much fun to analyze and he said well
what do you mean by data and I said you
know like you know there's the financial
books like the the quantities of craft
distilling and the prices and the wages
I named up all these things he kept on
nodding his head and say I'll have all
those but I don't know I never knew what
to do with them cuz they're just numbers
and I don't know anything about numbers
and so I said well can I get them and he
said sure and so that began the most
unequal partnership co-authoring
partnership in the history of mankind as
severe spent seven years living with the
gang going to jail being shot the car
windows being shot of his car and I
would sit back in my office waiting for
the next day to dump to come in so I
could put in my Excel spreadsheet and
you know spend 15 minutes as I like the
data before I sent him out in the field
to get some more data so let me tell you
this story about about how Sudhir got in
with the gang cuz it's my it's my my
favorite story although the problem with
the story said every punchline in this
story ends with a profanity so I
actually can't really tell the story
it's very effectively in this context
but in the book you get the you get the
unn the unabridged version so so Sudhir
had been a suburban college kid and he's
he's he's South Asian very dark-skinned
did he accompany IRISA Chicago to study
sociology as we say in the book and he
had spent the previous four months
following the Grateful Dead okay and so
he looked the part so he had hair you
know here all the way down his back and
he's you know a big guy but you know he
was dark-skinned but not black and he
had long hair so it was kind of bending
you know gender lines as well and so he
came to Willie rule in Julius Wilson
who's one of the great sociologists of
our time and he was doing a book about
when jobs disappear in Chicago here
sending out graduate students to do
surveys all around the city of Chicago
so he took one look at Sudhir and he
said this is the guy I've needed to send
to the housing project because he didn't
have a lot of graduate students he felt
comfortable sending to the housing
project so Sudhir marches down to the
housing project with a clipboard in hand
and set of questions and somebody comes
up to the buildings and these were
buildings that were virtually abandoned
and you know he they done this very
complicated randomization based on the
last census of which doors he was
supposed to knock on and now there's
nobody there basically he's walking
around but he's you know trying hard
it's getting dark and so we hear some
voices up in the stairwell so he figures
he'll go up the stairwell so he goes
around a stairwell and he comes up on
some some young males you know halfway
between kids and men and they're
shooting guys and so they're alarmed
they're not used to people coming around
the court especially not people that
look like yeah I'm career on the corner
and they leap up and turns out one kids
got a gun in series actually doesn't
know what it is for a while he's not
used to having guns it's like the kids
wagging a gun in his face but it's dark
so I can't really tell it is and so you
know they're like what are you doing
here and he says well I'm from the
University of Chicago and I wanted to
give you a survey and so so that's not
even the funny parts and the funny part
is the first question so I said okay
give us the first question okay and I
swear to god he says this is true
although it's it's I don't believe it
the first question is how does it feel
to be poor in black in America and the
choices are very good good
bad and very bad those are the four
choices that they have so he quickly
learns it turns on this that the the
true answer he gets whenever yes a
question is and it involves a lot of
profanity I'm not allowed to actually
yeah I probably can't say that answer in
this group so that didn't really improve
his his status with these folks when he
asked those questions and so they didn't
know what to do with them they ended up
holding him hostage overnight and and so
they're drinking beers and and he's
drinking beers and you know he's asking
him so there's a lot of gunshots going
off in the distance and he's he's asking
them all sorts of questions about their
lives and how they feel about death and
whatnot and they still don't have no
idea what to make out of it and so you
know since they're drinking beer they go
they go to the bathroom up and this and
this stairwell one floor above so we
just go in there too so he does that you
know makes it through the night and in
the morning they finally decide that
they can let him go I mean I have no
idea what he's doing that he still
they've figured out and so what he does
more or less as it goes home takes a
shower and then goes back to spend the
night with him again the next night okay
so when he shows up you know they're
like what do you what are you doing back
here he says well I enjoyed hanging out
with you so much last night I thought
maybe we could do it again and so that
in the end is how he starts to get in
with the gang and then literally what he
does for the next seven years it's been
all of his days and many of his nights
in the housing project with the gang
literally going to jail with them and
you know literally getting his car
window shot up getting the police to
plant crack cocaine in his vehicle and
arrest him for because the police didn't
like the fact that he was hanging out
documenting what was going on in these
neighborhoods in which the police were
choosing not to do anything about the
drug trade and and so what came out of
the research I think what's what's
what's great about it this is data no
one's ever had so first of all no one
has really ever been in the gang the way
subir was in the gang so it was you know
they all knew so I should make they're
all the gang members knew what he was up
to and in fact he was started out he'd
give them what he wrote before
published anything and no one and they
could not figure out what he was doing
because like he couldn't know why anyone
want to read the stuff that he would
write and and they felt sorry for him it
turned out because for a number of
reasons number one he he didn't have a
job right so he was just hanging out
with him all day and I thought this guy
can't be doing very well
and number two we had very dark skin and
so they figured that he couldn't
possibly have much of a chance in
American society number three it turns
out he didn't drive he drove a really
crappy car and so they felt away from
that but but the big one he told me the
big thing that he said he only had one
girlfriend and so he couldn't be very
high-status if he only could could have
one girlfriend at a time and so all
those combined they felt sorry for him
and that's actually why they were so
helpful in giving him the data and
cooperating and answering her questions
so the combination of him having this
incredible knowledge and understanding
of the game and also being just
incredibly smart I mean it's like I
can't stress enough how how difficult I
think it is having read other
ethnography not to become completely a
booster for whatever group your study is
very hard for people who get so involved
in a culture to not just become
defenders of that culture but he was
smart enough to really keep an open eye
and then to have this data combined with
his insights was really something that
we never had and they were doing
prosecutions of the big gangs in Chicago
around the same time and what's
interesting is I talked to the lead
prosecutor and they had nothing like we
had their data was pathetic compared to
the data that we had and their knowledge
of the gang was pathetic so they they
would show me these scraps of facts as
they had intercepted and they were like
well if they just asked me I could have
mapped out the entire city then you know
I could I knew all this plus a lot more
so I'll come back to that at the end so
what do we learn did we learn anything
so I think we learned a lot it really
surprised me is sure now if I were
better a better economist I could have
predicted the results better than I did
so what do we learn from from the study
of the gang the first thing was just in
terms of the way the gang was structured
it was remarkably like a regular
Corporation and particularly in
particularly like McDonald's is really
it's it's it's it's the org chart of
this gang and it
identical they're both franchise
organizations and which there's some
guys at the top who make the big
decisions about brands and and you know
expansion of territory and but they
don't really do the day-to-day business
they sell the rights to a certain
territory say six week six blocks six
square blocks and there was a franchise
rights just like a McDonald's gets a
franchise a unique franchise to sell in
some certain area and the person who
runs the franchise is the entrepreneur
in the sense that that person has to
raise the money to either buy the
hamburger or buy the powder crack coke
the powder cocaine and then hire the
workers and whatever's left over at the
end of the day that more or less goes to
the owner of the franchise except
they've got to pay up some share of
royalties and in the case of the gang or
something 20 percent of revenues got
paid up to the top to the top people a
second similarity between McDonald's and
the gang were the wages so it turns out
to the guys at the top in this gang
we're making four or five hundred
thousand dollars a year but there were
only about six or seven of them maybe
ten of them who are making that kind of
money
the franchise owners in the sense the
local gang leaders they were making
about seventy five to a hundred thousand
dollars here which it turns out is
almost exactly if you read franchisee
magazine is exactly how much you expect
to make if you run a local McDonald's
franchise and then at the bottom it
turns out that just like the burger
flippers for making minimum wage that's
exactly what the guys who were actually
selling the drugs on the street corner
we're making and that's the result which
i think is the most shocking one to
people and what's the one that surprised
me notion that the that the street
corner sellers were really only making
minimum wage so a fact that goes with
that which makes it hard to understand
how it could be true is that at the same
time the death rates were very very high
so this was a violent time there were
gang wars going on I was right at the
peak of crack and so the death rates
were about seven percent per year in
this gang and those are death rates that
you would have trouble finding in a war
so in our soldiers in Iraq nothing close
to that in terms of in terms of death
rates it's more like one to two percent
a year for our soldiers in Iraq
I think you have to go to like you know
fighter pilots in World War one or yeah
it's just it's hard to find a group of
people who have that kind of death rate
in the book we talked about the official
most dangerous job in the US according
to the Bureau of Labor Statistics which
is a timber cutter but the death rates
they're on the job or something like you
know one in 2,000 per year so this is
orders of magnitude and really shows you
that in a very literal sense there was a
war going on on the streets in the inner
cities of America during the during you
know still but but especially during the
the peak of the crack epidemic so how do
you reconcile the fact that they're
making minimum wage and at the same time
they're having 7% chance of being killed
who would take that job and and that
that's the clock the biggest the biggest
puzzle and I think the answer is twofold
one is as we talked about in the book
the idea that it was a tournament that
that just like the you know the high
school football quarterback who's taking
steroids to do better because he's got
some pipe dream of making it to the
National Football League and just like
the homecoming queen who you know drives
out Hollywood and waits tables for the
next 15 years hoping she'll get a good
big break isn't as an actress there is
the drug trade is very much like these
other lucrative activities where almost
everyone toils in complete obscurity and
makes almost no money and then a few
people the top make superstar kinds of
wages and it really was the case that
that was what the gang members were
after so how do we know that well one
thing is we can we can follow the gang
members over time and see at what point
they drop out of the gang and it turns
out that as soon as these gang members
got to be about 20 or 21 and they saw
other people being promoted up the
hierarchy but they themselves were not
being promoted they would drop out of
the game and this was a game where you
could drop out it was not hard to drop
out and and their own words are also to
that effect you know I'm not going to be
singing on the corner forever it's
either I move up around
or move out I can't feed my family doing
this and so all that seems to to make
sense and then so the other question was
can you really believe they were making
so little money you know is it is it our
imagination were they lying and the data
where the data made up and I think the
answer that tells you that there are a
lot of things to tell you that they must
not be making very much money and one is
this idea about living with a mother so
the question why do they live with their
mothers because when they're only making
$5 an hour they don't really have a
choice it's the only people who could
afford not to live at home with the
people who had moved up pretty high in
the hierarchy another thing was that I
said before that the the burgers
slingers and flippers and the drug
dealers for making about the same amount
of money well they were the same people
it turned out that over half of the kids
who were selling drugs were
supplementing their income working you
know at fast-food chains and whatnot
which again is very clear indication
that if they were making so much money
in the gang they wouldn't have wouldn't
have been bothering to to to do that and
then the third indication was as part of
the deal
to get access with the gang and to to be
able to say survey them and you know get
their data they would occasionally ask
too dear for favors like to find good
jobs for those gang members who wanted
to to get out of the game and and he did
he accommodated them and he he had a
very good pipeline which led to good
jobs he knew the person who had the
concession to do the janitorial services
of the University of Chicago so it
turned out that in the minds of the drug
dealers being a janitor at the
University of Chicago was a great job
because it had benefits it was steady
work and and again it reinforces the
idea that that just was not a very
lucrative life at the bottom so one
thing I mean this is not in the book but
it's research I've done that follows up
with Sudhir that follows up on on that
work is so what happened to the kids
when they grew up so we're following
kids who were 16 17 18 well by the end
of the the period they were about 25 26
27 and so because of Sudhir's incredible
contacts within this community we were
able to follow up every kid who had
lived in one particular housing
to house every young male building every
every housing project building and and
see what they were doing roughly ten
years later and what was interesting and
surprising to me was that the the gang
members if you just look at the raw data
they were doing worse the former gay
marrige were doing worse than the than
the other kids but once you controlled
for just the the the slightest set of
characters and a few things that turned
out that the single most important
variable actually was was the mother
what's the the child's mother a crack
addict it turned out that was the best
predictor of both being in the gang and
having a worst life welcome what's your
control for a few things you found that
the gang members actually did just as
well in life it's an ongoing numbers
conditional I'm not dying so lots of the
gang members died but of the ones who
survived they actually their lives ten
years later looked amazingly similar so
in terms of the jobs they had and the
their marriage status and whether or not
they were currently in jail those kind
of things really so it very much seemed
like the the most dire predictions which
is that getting in the gang was going to
ruin your life you could never escape
really weren't true that indeed the only
real difference you could see between
the gang members and non-being rumors
ten years later were that they both had
the same amount of wages but the gang
members were making more illegal income
they they for instance were more likely
to they had slightly worse jobs but they
sold more drugs at their jobs to - you
know suburban white people who needed to
get access to the drugs that they
actually ended up compensating for their
lower wages that way so let me just
close and talking just a bit about the
the police so of course I was talking
about the trials that were going on at
the same time that we were getting this
data and publishing at work and so you
can imagine we worried a little bit
about what potential legal issues we
could be running into and in particular
we were worried that we would be
subpoenaed to get access to our data but
the thing is we were much more
frightened by the gang than we were by
the by the authorities
and so I said to Sudhir I said you know
if we get subpoenaed what do you think
what's gonna happen what do you think
will happen and he said well let's just
have to go to jail until the until the
grand jury is done and I said okay
and I could see how that was gonna be a
very good step for his career because I
got nothing you know what could be
better for a sociologist than to spend a
few months in jail and write about his
experiences being in jails but I
couldn't really see how it's gonna be
very beneficial to my crew so I said to
him I said okay that's fine but is the
gang gonna protect us in jail and he
said why no they're gonna protect me you
I'm not so sure about but the good news
was the authorities never came after us
they didn't seem to care enough about
our data to to give us any job so let me
stop there if that's appropriate and
then I'll take some questions
so what while we're waiting for a
question I'll say I usually teach I
teach 9:00 a.m. I teach undergraduates
and I can't tell you how much more
enjoyable it is they have like a glowing
set of faces he was smiling at me
instead of mostly sleeping past that
there was this precipitous drop in crime
okay so let me before you answer the
question let me explain to people who
when the audience don't know why you're
asking that question why you would be
asking so along with John Donahue who's
a here's a professor of law at Yale I
put forth a theory that suggested that
the one of the important reasons why we
saw this amazing unparalleled and
unexpected decline in crime roughly a
50% decline in crime in 1990s was
because of the legalization of abortion
with Roe versus Wade roughly 20 years
earlier and the idea being that unwanted
children are at greater risk for crime
and there's a lot of evidence and the in
the long-term evidence supporting that
and that legalization of abortion
reduced the number of unwanted children
and therefore you put those two together
there were 20 years later when those
kids grew up and meets their peak
primary years there were just few were
criminals there to do the crime okay so
that was that's our hypothesis and it's
and it's well supported by the data so
in terms of just the raw time series roe
v-- wade was 1973 of course anywhere
1973 and so the peak of crime in United
States depending on what you look it
looks like it's about 1991 and then
there's a steady decline for the for the
next ten years after but but our
hypothesis isn't really based on that
time series data I think you know there
are lots of the problem with using time
series data to support a hypothesis is
that there are lots of things that have
that pattern of you know they went up
for a while and they went down for a
while and things changing so really are
the motivation behind our or the
evidence behind our story the motivation
is really the theory then the evidence
behind it
has to do more with looking at very
precise changes so for instance if you
compare the in the mid 1970s despite the
legalization of abortion there were
radically different rates of abortion in
different states across the United
States so places like New York and
Washington DC had lots of legal
abortions and places like North Dakota
and Alabama had essentially zero illegal
abortions so even though the law had
changed there was no one providing the
abortions so if you look over the next
15 years and you divide states into high
abortion states in the mid 70s and
medium abortion states and low abortion
states okay so over the next 15 years if
you compare the crime trends they're
almost identical you see no difference
for the next 15 years of what the crimes
are going up and down in the same sorts
of patterns and it's only starting 16
years later that you start to see a
divergence between the crime and those
sets of states and it turns out over the
next decade the crime and the high
abortion states fell about 30 percent
relative to the the crime in the low
abortion states and all of that decline
in crime is concentrated solely among
those born after roe v wade that you
don't see any differences in the crime
patterns for those older than you know
born before 1973 so that's more the kind
of evidence that we use in the book do
you want to follow that up yeah I was
wondering if you checked out any other
variables for instance alcoholism drug
addiction homosexuality various kinds of
you know Sochi APPA the-- and so forth
yeah so we've looked at a lot of
different so in our in our analysis we
do try to control for alcohol
consumption at the level the unit of
analysis that we have and we do control
for things like prison in police and and
it is interesting so there's another
paper not work that I did but but two
researchers from Michigan have done that
finds that among the cohort that's born
right after roe v-- wade actually
there's a big drop in drug use as
teenagers and drug abuse as teenagers so
it kind of fits in that same story
there's also been evidence that
infanticide there was a killing of
children and both of babies and children
went
in the cohorts born immediately after
Roe versus Wade sort of a more and more
evidence piling up on that on that point
sure professor for what it's worth the
bomber crews during the Second World War
especially in the first year or two had
about a five percent chance of dying on
each on each mission they went out on
and given that they started with 20
missions as their requirement before
they could go home this was a fairly
lethal environment and if you look at
the Indy 500 drivers they have about a 1
or 2 percent chance of getting killed
doing the Indy it's actually but these
are both high adrenaline activities
there's a lot or there's a lot of
patriotism associated to being a soldier
in combat
I'm just startled that people would take
on this level of lethality for the whole
level of reward is it you know are they
are they not viewing themselves as
having much of a of a forward future
therefore the risks aren't that bad or
is it you know are they bad at economics
or game theory yeah it's a good question
we don't really know the answer we can
ask questions we look at the data we can
ask them questions and I think partly
partly they suffered from the same bad
decision-making that that maybe some of
you suffered from if you went out to
Silicon Valley in the middle of the
Internet boom thinking that you were
going to be the next wave of people
getting rich and so what happened was a
gang had before crack had never been
profitable it had been really more like
a rite of passage for for young men and
by the time they got to be 20 to 23
virtually everyone dropped out of the
game you couldn't make enough money in
the gang to really make a career out of
it and so what happened with crack is
that suddenly by virtue of the nature of
crack it was it was a desirable drug it
was a relatively high price drug it was
very high volume and so crack really
became a way to make a living in the
gang and what what the cohort we were
looking at didn't properly take into
account was two things the first thing
is that
the cohort right above them right so
this is these are the people who ran the
gang in 1985 would never leave so it
turns out in Chicago the same guys who
ran the gangs in 1985 are all still
running the gangs and so these so is
very what's it they don't go into
politics well tell you story about that
one as well and so these guys basically
ran the gang and they never gave up the
reigns and so the guys who thought
they're at the bottom and projected up
well people have always dropped out of
the gang at age 23 or 24 and then it'll
be my turn to take over they never got
to take over and so it's very much like
I think this parallel through that the
guys who were running the gang at that
time were kind of like the Bill Gates
generation right the people were in the
right place at the right time they were
the first young kids who knew about
computers and so Bill Gates and his
cohort made a ton of money just by
virtue of that and then the the analogy
would make in the gang is that this
cohort we're looking on is more like
pets.com it's it's it's where you came
in and you would see how a lot of other
people made money and you thought you
gonna make a lot of money too and it's a
total disaster you spent a lot of money
on Super Bowl ads and you don't sell
hardly any any dog food so let me tell
you so let me address the the question
of politics which is actually relevant
so supposedly there have been a deal
worked on this is all hearsay about how
the gang was going to be more or less
allowed to do what they wanted to do as
long as they stayed out of politics and
so right about the time when our data
ends our data end because the gang
decided to get involved in politics and
they ran their lawyer for Alderman and
he was doing pretty well and immediately
after that the police came down and
arrested every top member of the gang
including the gang leader that we were
collecting data from that that is the
abrupt end of our data because the the
gang leaders decided to get involved in
politics it's just I knew a lot of guys
who did the internet stuff I knew a lot
of people who started the Silicon Valley
business I actually hire people for
high-risk activities right now and but
you know the guys I hire work on
desperately trying to reduce risk
they've probably spent 90% of their
effort trying to understand control and
look forward and do these massive fault
tree analysis so that we can at least
look ourselves in the mirror the next
morning and I'm just I'm just startled
that not only you you're not including
in your analysis the negative downside
of doing five to ten years in prison I
mean getting killed is fairly minor
compared to seven years of getting it in
the well starting on the wrong part of
the Oz scenario it's up that last part
of the question go back to the first
part of the question which had to do
with with the calculation of risk and
I'll tell you a big difference between
people doing the risky jobs you're
talking about and his gang members it
has to do with incentives and how you
win this tournament so indeed the guy
who ran the gang he hated the violence
the violence was the worst thing that
could happen for him because unlike when
McDonald's and Burger King get into some
kind of a price war right they they
lower the prices but but more and more
people come so they make up to a certain
extent the the smaller margins on
quantity but in the gang it is it's the
opposite because when you start shooting
all of the all of the customers are
afraid to come in the neighborhood so
not only do your prices follow during
gang wars but your your quantity souls
fall as well so your profits basically
the game becomes a negative in terms of
profitability once these gang wars are
going on so you might say well why are
they doing this why can't they figure it
out you know I can't they they're close
to your risk of Chicago free markets and
coach theorem all these things about
efficient things why can't they figure
it out one of them should have to fight
and it turns out it has to do with
incentives because the guys at the
bottom all these guys at the bottom they
all want to move up and how do you
convince somebody you're the one to move
up and it turns out that being a guy
who's seen it's a little bit crazy
willing to kill willing to start fights
not afraid of anything is the recipe for
moving up and so it's actually a real
problem within the organization in terms
of incentives that the guys at the
bottom have the incentive to you know to
be seen as killers to be killers so they
can take over the top whereas the guys
at the top have every incentive for them
not to be killers both because it's you
know they're going to be the targets in
the long run potentially but also
because it hurts business and so I think
that's part of it you know it's like a
the violence was actually part of the of
the goal of the guys at the bottom for
for making it to the top and look into
the cost of just doing five years in
jail I've talked to a lot of people
about your book who are really surprised
that this is economics and I'm an
economics major and this is kind of the
stuff that I do I'm wondering if you
could explain I think this is the core
of economics whereas a lot of people
would say this is some strange arm so
there's wondering if you could give me
your definition of economics the same
okay well make sure if I ever do another
book reading I'm gonna bring you in have
you asked so why do I think this is
economics so many people classify
economics in terms of a subject matter
or a topic right so it's its interest
rates its macroeconomic fluctuations
things like that and I think that's just
totally wrong I mean I think what
economics really should be thought of is
there's a set of tools
it's coming it's a set of tools for
understanding human behavior it's a set
of ideas about how to use data so one of
the things about economists if we don't
have the luxury of actually being able
to do randomized experiments right so in
the hard science physical sciences and
even in psychology you can do
experiments and so you don't have to
think hard about what you would do in
the absence of randomized experiments
cuz you can do the experiments but you
know when I put in my grant to the
National Science Foundation that says I
want to lock up a hundred thousand extra
people and release a hundred thousand
you know prisoners from a different
state they always reject those grants so
I've got to find another way to try and
answer questions like that so we have
these set of data tools that are
designed to to go out in the real world
and use what we call natural experiments
or to come up with answers and the third
thing I think that special about
economics is that it it it's not
shackled by political correctness at all
that that you can ask whatever question
you want and no matter how outrageous
the answer is other economists at least
will nod their head say okay that makes
sense and they don't worry very much
about what the broader up the cases
aren't so in that sense I think that's
where this really fits in as economics
is that it has the elements of being
about looking at all kinds of human
behavior and the last thing I guess
would say is incentives
really I I am an economist in the sense
that I very much view the world through
the lens of its sentence but more more I
focus on kind of the dark side of
incentives most most economists think
that incentives are the tool that can
solve any problem and if you just give
them the right you know the right you
know power economists could make the
world a really good place to be whereas
in this book we really focus on well so
economists or politicians set up in the
center scheme and then everybody else
goes out and says okay how can I beat it
you know what is it what is it what can
I do to figure out how to you know beat
the system and I think that's just as
important part of economic system Thanks
I was wondering how dependent people in
your business in economics are on
ethnographers like mr. Venkatesh and the
studies that he does not nearly as
dependent as we should be I can name
really on one hand I think the set of
economists I know who are actually
interested in ethnography and who read
it voraciously
I think that's a problem in some sense
that that I find I always learned more
from reading ethnography than I do from
reading other economics papers usually
and and my hope is that in the future
there'll be more more collaboration
although I will say and this might be
partly apocryphal but but so when when
Sudhir was being looked at for a job in
the anthropology department at the
University of Chicago the way it's told
to me and I'm sure I'm gonna get in a
lot of trouble for saying this on c-span
but anyway so the way it's told to me is
the following so he did very well in the
job talk that you give and then there's
a half an hour session afterwards in
which you discuss your future research
what you plan to do so he made the
mistake in that half an hour afterwards
and saying well there's this really
interesting economist we shared the same
building upstairs that I'm working with
to try to study the issues of gangs and
gang finances to which my impression was
that his candidacy immediately ended
because anyway the answer polish thought
anybody who thinks working with
economists is the right way to do things
must be not really big belong in our
department so it
didn't get the job and then so I was
relaying this story to my colleagues and
they said to me well but of course you
know if you didn't already have tenure
the fact that you're working with an
anthropologist would be just as damaging
to you and this department is this vice
versa so I think there's not enough
there should be a lot more and and kind
of I have a I think many people have a
view that that that academics should be
more interdisciplinary and I actually
think that that's not the right model
because the problem is it's too hard to
even be good at your own discipline much
less to be good at other people's
disciplines and so I kind of have a
model of being more what I would call a
disciplinary where you take a set of
data tools and you don't pretend I would
never want to pretend that I could be a
decent ethnographer you know I can
barely make it as an economist and so to
think that I would suddenly be qualified
to do ethnography would be silly but to
kind of break down the barriers and and
work it's it's hard to fight the right
personality so it takes it takes special
people the kind of people who
self-select into say anthropology for
seeking out they're so different to
begin with that's hard to find two
people who can work together and and
make headway the way Sudhir and I did
but I really think it was referred for
us a great model and and turned out far
better research than either of us could
have done on her thank you for the
question all right
um real quick question has doing the
research for this book or any of your
other studies given you I suppose and
the interesting thoughts concerning
human rationality I'm not I'm not big on
human rationality I'm not you know I'm
from Chicago and we're supposed to be
you know big fans of human rationality
but I think I think rationality is such
a loaded word because it comes with this
idea of you know being able to do really
complicated calculations in your head
and having full information and I think
in general for most of what we do number
one we don't have very full information
and number two it's not worth our time
to really necessarily try to get things
exactly right and so a lot of economists
are working about irrationality and
other models but more I think I think a
better way to think about it has to do
with incentive said basically people
people try to do what's good for them
okay and it's it's not that they
necessarily always get it right but that
more often than not if you if you set up
things to encourage their behavior in
one direction you can influence their
behavior in one direction it's not you
know it goes far beyond humans it's true
of rats and pigeons in the lab you can
very much make them respond and also
putting in a plug for for Dubner and my
next adventure which is we're going to
be writing a monthly column for the
sunday New York Times and so our first
sunday New York Times column is about
monkeys and what economists are now
doing with monkeys and what we're
learning about monkeys and money and
monkeys spend their money when you give
it to it and so and there again you see
monkeys in the end like a whole lot like
human beings they you know they're like
rational in some senses and irrational
in other cities I was wondering what
about the actual business aspect I mean
keeping books retirement plans and stuff
like that within the game so yeah so and
also also the second part of the
question is I mean the banking and all
of that stuff I'm interested in that and
then what aspects of legitimate business
mimic gang mimic the game yeah that's a
hard question let me take the first one
so in terms of keeping books this gang
was somewhat unusual and indeed they
were keeping books precisely because
their gang leader had been this guy who
had worked in the amass Department
downtown and had a college degree and
had seen how to use you know he knew how
to use Lotus type spreadsheets and was
using these I should say using these
books to impress the higher-ups and
actually was very successful in showing
them how good he was at doing business
and moving up to the top in terms of
retirement benefits given the death
rates you might not be surprised that
they were not investing heavily in these
things but what the gang did do was they
paid off a lot of money if a gang member
got killed they paid a fair amount of
money so they paid I forget the exact
number two or three years worth of the
typical salary
I was paid to the family of the victim
and they would pay for the funeral
expenses and and in their talk they
talked about how it was because they're
all family and they had to do it but I
think you know my more more cynical view
was that manure getting killed it was
always bad for the gang and the
community support for the gang and so
they were in some sense trying to buy
off the loyalty on on the kinds of you
know I don't have a good answer to that
question about how corporations were
mimicking the gang I mean one thing I
think it's interesting is that when you
look at the gang that they were very
self-consciously mimicking the
corporations so they were calling the
the top level of the gang was called the
Board of Directors and they were
watching movies like Wall Street and
taking their clues from pop culture when
what's interesting is that so at the
same time that all the suburban kids
were like worrying Oakland Raiders
jackets and trying to be like the gang
members the inner city kids were
watching Wall Street and trying to be
like the parents of the kids who were
wearing the Oakland Raiders jacket so I
think there's I have no cultural
observer but I think there's something
interesting in the in the that cultural
phenomena I'd like to ask you an
economic question that's been bothering
me for years I'd like to ask you an
economic question that's been bothering
me for years I'm an open source advocate
programmer and it seems to me physically
that that's much the better way to go
and yet it's not being successful and I
don't understand why I wonder how you as
an economist would look at that problem
as it is it's a problem clear to you
yeah so if I understand open source the
idea is that you make the code available
to everyone so that's very easy for
other people to build on it now I mean
and I think the economic answer to that
and there's a much better economist in
the back Chris Mader who could I'm sure
answered this question better than you
so Chris if I give the wrong answer you
got
come up here and give the right answer
but the I mean I think the obvious
answer is that you know the way the way
you can charge high prices for stuff is
if you've got something that no one else
can replicate and so getting the you
know so so you know the idea of a patent
excludes anyone from doing another drug
with the idea of making a system that
nobody else can hook into I mean so we
saw it with like beta versus VHS is like
there were two completely different
standards it was incredibly inefficient
but the one who was going to win felt
like they had more two more to gain by
winning on their own standard than by
being open so I mean I think on the
other hand they are good economic
arguments for why open-source is good if
you get rid of a lot of this you know
the difficulties of you know why my
blackberry doesn't work when I'm in
China which you know there's no good
reason for you know why that shouldn't
be the case if everybody just cooperated
long so I mean those are I mean those
are there are competing forces on on
both sides and I think in some cases you
see people collaborating on standards
and in other cases you see people doing
their best to prevent that and and I
think I think they're there dim forces
that sometimes will push you either
direction
about gangs is this the mic was that the
mic yeah I just I just want to say so I
just want the people who are in line now
to be able to answer question so in
other words nobody joins the line okay
what about family you know when we read
when we see The Godfather there are
families at the top of gangs that's not
an economic kind of a thing that's the
way power is transferred and want many
societies whether it's capitalism
communism or whatever how did that
influence the people who are coming up
or the culture of the game yeah that's a
good question
so the gangs in some sense are too young
of organizations to have this kind of
structure already built in it was really
he's really the night these gangs
emerged in the 1960s but but they had
never they weren't businesses and so
there was no there was no family passage
in the in the regular sort of way now it
is true that if you're you know father
had been a gang member to pick the gang
in the 60s that might have made it more
likely that you would be in that gang
growing up but but they really didn't
become money-making endeavors until the
mid 80s it's it's it's kind of like the
parallel to the again to the Internet
boom we're like Microsoft so you know
it's probably unlikely that Bill Gates
his kids are gonna eventually run
Microsoft in the same way that it hasn't
been the case that the that the gang
leaders kids necessarily have risen up
to to control these these street gangs
Steven Levitt teaches economics at the
University of Chicago freakonomics a
rogue economist explores the hidden side
of everything as number two on this
week's New York Times nonfiction
bestseller list it's published by
william morrow an imprint of
HarperCollins visit
HarperCollins com for more information